[Musique]
bonsoir jacques les protestations donc
un temps de la direction que des
syndicats d'edf devant la la décision du
gouvernement de plafonner ces tarifs des
tonnes mais au fait qui décide du prix
de l'électricité en france voilà on l'a
bien vu avec le plafonnement à 4% pour
l'instant c'est encore l'état et ça
devrait le rester en tous les cas
jusqu'à 2025 mais en réalité normalement
depuis l'introduction de la concurrence
eh bien ça devrait être le marché qui
définit le prix le seul problème c'est
que ben voilà l'électricité ne se stocke
pas ça n'a pas les caractéristiques d'un
produit normal et donc parler d'un
marché de l'énergie c'est en fait un
abus de langage il n'y a pas de réel
marché sur ces questions là alors donc
parmi ses multiples un distributeur mais
tout d'abord qu'en est il par jallet je
me précipitais jacques en est il de
cette mise en concurrence tout d'abord
et bien l'europe qui est absolument
obsédé je dirais parle par les règles de
concurrence a décidé donc d'ouvrir le
marché de l'électricité à la concurrence
alors on sait que l'électricité pour
arriver jusqu'aux consommateurs faut
quatre étapes il ya la production bien
entendu il ya le transport il ya la
distribution et il ya la fourniture ce
que l'europe a décidé de privatiser
c'est essentiellement la distribution et
la fourniture maintenant les nouveaux
fournisseurs ça essayer ses fournisseurs
privés eh bien ils sont obligés
d'acheter leur électricité à des grands
producteurs et de la faire transiter
parce que le transport non plus n'est
pas réellement privatiser sur les
réseaux par exemple en france deux
compagnies comme rte ou aînés disent
qu'ils sont toujours des filiales d'edf
alors parmi 1 c'est un multiple
distributeur de courant et que nous
connaissons aucun produit réellement
l'électricité qu'il vend alors s'il y en
a quelques-uns qui produisent de
l'électricité par exemple les
producteurs historiques à edf total
energy and gibbons mais c'est vrai que
les 40
distributeurs privés qui est mise en
vente la majorité ils ne produisent rien
ils se contentent d'acheter et très
souvent ce sont des structures qui sont
soit très petit soi même qui sont
complètement virtuel qui n'existent que
sur internet le problème évidemment
c'est que ça donne la main aux grands
producteurs historiques et ça veut dire
aussi que d'une certaine manière et bien
ce marché il reste très virtuel pourquoi
virtuel alors il va rester virtuel pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord un premier
élan c'est évidemment la question des
prix on voit très bien que la
concurrence a fait monter les prix on le
voit en particulier sur le graphique et
on voit d'ailleurs que cette hausse des
prix elle s'est accélérée depuis
l'ouverture à la concurrence par exemple
en moyenne par an avant l'ouverture à la
concurrence les prix n'augmenter que de
1,2 à 1,4 pour cent depuis l'ouverture à
la concurrence il augmente autour de 2,2
et probablement plus si on regarde la
dernière période où on voit bien que la
pente est très très très raide bon si on
ajoute à cela les frais de compteurs ce
qu'on appelle en fait les frais
d'installation est bien c'est de 2,8 par
8% par an que ça augmentait donc on voit
bien qu'il y avait effectivement une
forte augmentation 1 mais c'est au cesc
elles traduisent une envolée de la
production alors et c'est là où
justement vous avez raison de poser le
problème en réalité la production en
france se fait à des coûts relativement
faible pour deux raisons alors on voit
sur le graphique 71 % de l'électricité
qui est produite en france ça vient du
nucléaire après vous avez les barrages
le secteur hydraulique 11% donc 82 % au
total les énergies fossiles pétrole gaz
charbon ne représente que 10% donc le
résultat c'est que normalement nous
devrions avoir des coûts extrêmement
faible de l'énergie sauf que dans ce
mécanisme de concurrence ce qu'impose
l'union européenne c'est que le prix de
l'énergie soit calculée à partir du
kilowattheure dit marginal ce qu'on
appelle la tarification au coût marginal
chose qui était inventée en france au
début des années 60 et qu'est ce que ça
veut dire c'est que ce kilowattheure
marginal il est produit essentiellement
dans des centrales à gaz des centrales
au pétrole voir le pire dans des
centrales au charbon dans le cas par
exemple de l'allemagne ou de la pologne
et il coûte beaucoup plus cher que ce
que coûte le kilowattheure en moyenne
produits dans des installations qui sont
maintenant je dirais
qu'ils existent depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années et qui sont
complètement amortis et à qui cela
profite est évidemment au grand
producteur historique parce que leurs
coûts de production sont très inférieurs
au coût marginal
d'autant plus que là nous sommes depuis
ces derniers mois dans une situation où
le prix du gaz en particulier mais c'est
vrai pour l'ensemble des hydrocarbures
il monte au plafond donc c'est on est
dans une situation où les grands
producteurs historiques vont se faire
une marge considérable qu'est ce que ça
veut dire mais ça veut dire en fait qu'
on est dans une situation où ils vont
prendre de l'argent dans la poche du
consommateur
pour d'une certaine manière s'enrichir
et tout ça au nom de la concurrence qui
aurait dû aboutir à une baisse des coûts
on voit bien là l'un cohérence globale
de ce système et c'est donc pour cela
que des f bouillonne alors oui edf
protestent parce qu'évidemment elle va
non pas perdre de l'argent mais moins
gagné d'argent
si par exemple on avait accepté les 45%
45 % 1 de hausse qui était normalement
prévu ne part si vous voulez ce système
de concurrence alors il faut toujours
rappeler que l'état se garde ou va
garder jusqu'en 2025 une possibilité
d'user ce qu'on appelle la rer à chaud
je sais
ça veut dire
accord réguler sur l'énergie nucléaire
historique on va pas leur et me voilà
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que jusqu'en 2025 l'état a le droit
de calais les prix réglementés sur la
base du coût de l'électricité produit
par les centrales nucléaires qui existe
historiquement en france mais on voit
bien que ça ça ça pénalise d'une
certaine manière edf et puis on voit
surtout bien que cette mesure elle ne va
rester que jusqu'en 2025 qu'est-ce qui
se passera après ça personne ne le sait
alors finale que dit cette crise ouverte
entre edf et le gouvernement alors cette
crise ouverte elle nous dit trois choses
importantes la première chose c'est que
le gouvernement il se trouve aujourd'hui
piégé par cette situation une situation
dont les différents gouvernements sous
nicolas sarkozy
sous françois hollande sous emmanuel
macron ont pourtant favorisé aucun de
ces gouvernement n'a remis en cause le
principe de la concurrence et de la
privatisation dans le domaine de
l'énergie sauf qu'aujourd'hui de quoi se
rendre qu'il combat ils se rendent
compte que bah si on avait face et les
français devaient subir une hausse du
tarif de l'électricité 2 45% nous sommes
quand même en année électorale et il ya
de fortes chances que ça ait des
conséquences plutôt néfaste sur la cote
des manuels macron donc ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est
aussi que économiquement il voit très
bien qu'il ne peut pas se permettre ce
genre de hausse pourquoi parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d entreprises qui consomment de
l'énergie est confronté à une hausse des
tarifs de 45% et bien un certain nombre
d'entreprises le ministère dit 150 y en
a peut-être plus elle ferait faillite
troisième problème que l'on a passé le
consommateur alors le consommateur
d'abord mais il se rend compte qu'avec
la concurrence y payent plus cher que ce
qu'il devrait et puis surtout le
consommateur civet un petit peu
écologique il à se poser une question
comment se fait-il qu'il doit payer un
prix qui correspond à des centrales à
gaz des centrales à charbon ou des
centrales au fioul alors que l'énergie
en france elle est massivement produite
par le nucléaire et par l'hydraulique
deux sources d'énergie qui ne produisent
pas de ce2 et qui sont particulièrement
verte donc là aussi il y à une
contradiction flagrante qui vient de ce
processus de mise en concurrence cette
privatisation dans le domaine de
l'électricité et bien merci de nous
avoir avertis jacques merci à vous et à
la semaine prochaine pour un nouvel
d'amérique nous et commercy